saludos acabo de charlar con el famoso
piloto de la pista de indianápolis
jf hillebrand hablamos sobre la pista de
carreras de indianápolis que les muestra
aquí y le pregunté algo que siempre me
ha dado mucha curiosidad ya que el tomar
las curvas parece algo muy importante en
las carreras de autos y mi pregunta es
cuál es la mejor forma de tomar una
curva será tratar de minimizar la
distancia tomando la curva más cerrada
es decir la que tiene la menor distancia
como lo que estoy dibujando aquí aunque
cuando hacemos esto se tiene más fuerza
g más fuerza centrípeta que las llantas
y el conductor tienen que soportar
o será que conviene más tomar la curva
más abierta es más larga pero cuya
aceleración centrípeta o fuerzas que son
menos dramáticas
yo le hice estas preguntas a mi amigo y
él me comentó que cada pista de carreras
es un poco diferente y en el ejemplo de
la pista de indianápolis la parte de la
curva es como la de una pista de
carreras de atletismo de 800 metros es
la distancia más corta que se puede
tener del punto a al punto b en esta
pista
cada vuelta en la pista es igual por lo
que me importa recorrer una distancia
específica mi amigo también me comentó
que en la realidad un auto no puede
tomar así una curva cerrada ya que
tomara si la curva genera la mayor
cantidad de trabajo en la pista de
indianápolis se aproxima uno a la
primera curva a casi 240 millas por hora
y esta primera curva es bastante plana a
diferencia de las pistas de carreras de
nascar en talladega o daytona que son
unas pistas enormes y que están
diseñadas para que los autos tengan
mucha velocidad en este caso el auto
tiene que realizar mucho trabajo al dar
las vueltas aquí
entonces yo le pregunté a mi amigo si
era mejor tomar la curva más abierta la
que está hacia afuera y él me respondió
que si vemos la curva más cerrada como
parte de una circunferencia más o menos
como la estoy dibujando aquí y viéramos
su radio notaremos que es un círculo
pequeño bueno relativamente pequeño
si hiciéramos lo mismo con la curva más
abierta pues su circunferencia quedaría
así con un radio más grande por lo que
en ésta tendríamos menos fuerza
centrípeta en comparación con el círculo
más pequeño
así que aquí afuera tendríamos menos
aceleración hacia dentro o menos fuerzas
g
me comenta que si tratamos de
imaginarnos a un autor recorriendo estos
dos círculos diferentes con la misma
velocidad en ambos se realizará menos
trabajo en el círculo más grande por lo
que la velocidad a la que podríamos
llegar en este círculo aumenta aunque el
auto tiene una habilidad limitada para
poder adherirse al suelo de la pista mi
amigo me comentó que para calificar en
la pista de indianápolis no se puede
disminuir la velocidad y aunque al usar
los frenos el auto puede tomar esta
curva cerrada sin problemas si se quiere
lograr el tiempo requerido para
calificar en esta pista no se puede
frenar ningún momento se tienen que
lograr las mejores 4 vueltas de la
temporada o incluso las 4 mejores
vueltas de toda la carrera para
calificar en indianápolis así que no se
puede usar el freno con estas
condiciones el auto no puede tomar la
curva más pequeña ya que va a toda
máquina para lograr el tiempo necesario
para calificar así que hay que buscar la
ruta en la curva que sea más eficiente
en este ejemplo buscamos aumentar el
radio pasando del círculo morado al
círculo verde como lo estoy dibujando
aquí más o menos con este tono blanco
y es así como se encuentra la ruta
óptima para tomar la curva comenzamos
desde la parte más externa llevando el
auto hacia la parte interna de la pista
en la curva y después regresar a la
parte más externa de la pista usando
todo el espacio disponible esta
respuesta no me la esperaba ya que en mi
mente yo solo visualizaba estos dos
círculos pero mi amigo me hizo ver que
hay otro círculo más grande que cabe
aquí
y cuyo centro está más o menos por acá
por lo que tenemos aún menor aceleración
centrípeta o aceleración hacia adentro
que sufre el auto así que el auto puede
aumentar muchísimo su velocidad en las
curvas que es lo que se busca en las
carreras mi amigo me comentó que el
hacer esto cuando se es piloto de
carreras es algo inconsciente cuando se
maneja el auto de carreras no se usa la
matemática para encontrar la mejor ruta
uno sigue lo que el auto quiere hacer
pero me comenta que viéndolo desde esa
perspectiva y sabiendo que en la parte
recta de la pista el auto puede ir a
unas 240 millas por hora es casi la
velocidad máxima a la que puede llegar
el auto la barrera que forma el aire
frente al auto no va a permitir que se
vaya más rápido el motor ya va a todo lo
que da y no se puede acelerar más así
que lo que hacen los corredores para
lograr un mejor tiempo en la curva que
coincide con la mayor velocidad promedio
que se tiene en la vuelta
hacer que el auto atraviese las curvas
de la manera más eficiente para poder
acelerar lo más posible en los tramos
rectos esto se logra creando una curva
con el radio más grande posible y es así
como encontramos esta línea óptima y
esto a mí me parece fascinante